put in some audio should be able to hear
me now hey everybody welcome to I
hesitate to call this Astro coffee
hangout because it really isn't we're
gonna change the branding here in just a
little bit but I didn't have anything
handy but today what your call it what
you're watching is something well Brian
and I'll talk about in just a minute
anyway today we're gonna this is
something we're trying a little bit new
here on my channel and also on Brian
Keeney's channel we should be streaming
on all the channels just to let you guys
know are I'm looking at I'm looking at
twitch my youtube channel Twitter and
periscope
I'm sorry Twitter and Facebook so if you
comment on any of those I can see them
let me bring up dr. Bryan Keating with
me now he died hey Brian how are you I'm
great Tony I'm really looking forward to
this new new project that we're
hopefully gonna keep going for a while
yeah let's talk about it a little bit so
we're gonna just spend maybe two or
three minutes on it then we're gonna
dive into our topic but Brian and I were
talking about ways in which we can
collaborate more and one of the ideas
that we had is that Brian actually has
access to someone he does some amazing
interviews and he's interested primarily
in interviewing authors of books but
it's all on his channel and so I wanted
to give you guys a glimpse at what he's
doing so that when you if you want to
learn more I will actually watch the his
full video or a full interview then you
can go to his channel and watch it
because we're gonna kind of whet your
appetite with the topics of various
interviews that he's done here and
because their book interviews I want to
rebrand this for away from Astro coffee
it's just the one thing I had that was
the most close to what we're doing and
we're gonna cut what were we gonna call
it Brian we're gonna pasteurize maybe
like book scope or book observatory
maybe we'll do a little poll what do you
guys think well yeah give us a servitor
barry in all this yeah and all the chats
let us know what you give us some ideas
here and we'll we'll call it that and
we'll get a graphic made and and all of
that the idea here is that on the
Thursdays where I'm not doing any
sponsored hangouts from the American
Astronomical Society that these Thursday
is open right so we're gonna go ahead
and keep it going by doing stuff like
this so and today we're going to be
talking about your well do do you want
to get some background on maybe what
you're doing over on your channel with
it's interviews and stuff like that then
we'll talk about steve-o you know as
I've been on the your show a few times
now and people that might remember or
maybe if you're new to the channel or
new to me I am a professor I teach
physics and astronomy at the University
of California San Diego and in the
course of my my career I've always been
fascinated by books and in fact I never
thought I would write a book but I end
up writing a book called losing the
Nobel Prize which was published in 2018
about the experiences that I had as a
young scientist basically a mentor to a
student and then becoming a mentor
myself and dealing with a lot of
emotions and rides ups and downs and
trying to uncover what happened at the
beginning of time if indeed there was a
single beginning of time and that story
was cataloged there and it was really
came about because of the influence of
just a few authors that had influenced
me as a young child up until the time I
wrote the book and so I always wanted to
do a book but I never knew if I'd have
the ability to time the resources to do
it and I ended up realizing that the
story of the bicep2 acclaimed discovery
of inflationary gravitational wave
impact on the Cosmic Microwave
Background provided such a such a venue
for me to tell a story which had never
been told before and to make matters
better I was intimately involved in the
project and then the aftermath of it as
well as with the selection of the
winners of the Nobel Prize in 2016 and
so I want the catalog that for kind of
posterity and also use it as an
opportunity for a legacy for my children
my biological children and also my
ideological children the students that
I've been blessed to have so I wrote
that book and you know I don't know if
I'll ever write another book but the
point was that I got to interact and get
the feedback from so many great authors
ranging from lord martin rees to
sir roger penrose and many many luminous
authors around the world and i couldn't
be more happy to have remained friends
with them and what i'm trying to do in
this era of kovat nineteen I realized
that many of these authors are putting
out phenomenal books but they're not
getting the opportunity to go on a book
tour
all book tours have been cancelled as of
early March so I've gotten some
phenomenal guests that quite frankly I
probably couldn't have gotten weren't
for the impact on book sales and book
promotions and my niche is in science
nonfiction and I've tried to take
advantage of that actually some other
things as well but mostly related around
either academic freedom or free speech
kind of things as well as mostly 90% of
what I do our science books so we
started the podcast probably two years
ago and it's part of my role at UCSD s
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination the podcast is called in to
the impossible tony and the reason that
has that name some of your listeners and
our our listeners might know is that's
the the title of sir arthur c clarke
second law everybody knows his first law
which is any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
the second law of his of arthur c clarke
who is a science nonfiction writer and a
science fiction writer he's kind of
emblematic of what i like to do and what
i'm interested in his second law was to
find out what's possible you must go a
little bit into the impossible very nice
and so that's what we're doing so we're
interviewing brilliant minds so i've
already had on some tremendous thinkers
including stephen wolfram and you know
what I found out today Tony this is you
know one of my highlights as an academic
stephen wolfram follows five people on
Twitter sorry no no no I'm sorry I'm
sorry
he follows one person on Twitter and
you're looking at Oh companies and he
follows one person and for some reason I
tweeted out today that that he is is
following me
and it's it's kind of cute it to be in
that position they're awesome like
stephen stephen wolfram that's great
okay yeah
all right and we're gonna be talking
about it yeah exactly so so most of you
were chatting I just will acknowledge
some of the chats here yeah you know the
you guys are suggesting topics like
gravitational waves and things like that
we can absolutely do those things but
we're going to and we'll we'll read you
will use your ideas as feedback for
future ones future shows like this I
think it just so everybody's clear I
think that you're gonna be on for about
a half an hour and then you're gonna go
right because yeah okay yeah I'm
schooling for my kids and for my
graduate students as well so but I
commit yeah we can go a little bit
longer maybe until you know 20 to the to
the next hour okay I just want it yeah I
want to give you a few guys they're on a
time crunch then I want to make sure
that you are you know I respect your
time in that way all right well so there
is apparently today's topic is about one
of the interviews that you that you had
recently done with Stephen Wolfram and
apparently I don't know anything about
this but apparently there is a
controversy surrounding what he's doing
so you want to set the stage and then I
will play your video clip yeah so many
of your listeners might know that the
so-called Holy Grail in physics is to
come up with what's known as a theory of
everything a theory that would unite the
four fundamental forces of nature which
are electromagnetism the two types of
nuclear forces called the strong and the
weak force and then the force of gravity
and to date we've had Inklings of how
the first three of those can be unified
that so called a lecture a weak theory
quantum chromodynamics in the case of of
the nuclear reactions but we haven't
been able to unify those three very high
energy forces with the weakest force of
all which is gravity which is kind of
unusual right because we think of
gravity is pretty strong especially if
you tried to go to the gym and lift some
weights but it's actually the weakest
force which gives it some benefit in
that it can pervade the entire universe
unlike say the nuclear force which can't
escape of confines of the nucleons which
is about 10 to the 28th meters range
versus the force of gravity can
act over you know 10 to the 28th
positive meters in range so what's so
fascinating and has vexed physicists
since the time of Einstein really this
is Einsteins unfinished symphony in some
sense he wanted to unify all four laws
of nature into one in particular to
understand how quantum mechanics the
theory of the very small the subatomic
microscopic could be combined
mathematically when I say the theory of
everything I mean that the math is
described and perhaps a single equation
and that single equation encodes the
properties of how gravity performs on
quantum mechanical scales so fractions
of the size of a nanometer perhaps so
what Einstein tried to do is ultimately
unsuccessful and what I see Stephen
Wolfram doing along with other people
that I'm hoping to have on my show next
week
Eric Weinstein who's a renowned
intellect he's the managing director of
Peter Thiel's teal Capital Group of
course Peter Thiel the first investor in
facebook founder of PayPal and many
other companies Eric Weinstein is a
physicist mathematical physicist with a
degree from from Harvard and he's come
up with a new theory called geometric
unity which shares in common one crucial
fact with that of Steven Wolfram's
so-called physics project they're both
trying to come up with a law that
unifies all the laws of physics under
one rubric under one umbrella and you
could you can wonder well how could they
be happy to be two theories I mean
shouldn't it be Z theory of everything
and that's probably true but in in the
context of both of these gentlemen their
particular theories have been absolutely
shredded and assailed on the internet by
pundits by eminent physicist and the
reaction to it has said a lot to me
about the sociology of science and how
people people can confront these biggest
topics possible and yet be sort of
almost to the level of ad hominem
attacks on ideas of very well-meaning
people and the reasons why we maybe we
can get into but it's been a study in
sociology to both these two gentlemen
putting out
theories of physics that purport to
answer the deepest question in nature
okay well hang on though isn't it I mean
I've got a lot to say about this idea of
a theory of everything that could be
like be printed on a t-shirt I just
don't think there's ever gonna come down
to that but but this idea that their
ideas are being you said shredded was
your term I mean come on that's science
right if they're if that's how science
works if you've got an idea it needs to
stand up to rigorous examination so I
mean okay the ad hominem attacks that's
that's it slightly that yeah that that's
sort of a sign of the time we live and I
think but the isn't that healthy to have
somebody really just like run your ideas
through the grinder so I think in the
night and early 20th century I mean
Einstein hated quantum mechanics didn't
he so yeah ya know and some of the
things that he would say you know the
really he didn't hide his disgust for it
but in the case of this of these two new
theories that are being put forth and
maybe today we'll just focus on Steven
won't from there's a there's been
criticism that he's putting this out
really you know as a way to grandstand
and the words of one physicist and as a
way to circumvent the ordinary rules by
which physics is supposed to be managed
and presented namely by presenting it
online and not in a refereed paper and a
prestigious Journal oh is that the
controversy is that with that problem
but but it's twofold Tony it's very
interesting because one part of it is
that one part of it is oh well it must
not be right because it's in this
journal and and it's not hasn't been
submitted or even power so that to me is
disappointing because I can I can give
you at some day some day well we should
sit down and talk about how many great
discoveries printed in the most
prestigious journal called nature or
science have been later retracted and
withdrawn even though they didn't write
that conversation for sure even to the
point that the other press conferences
held at the White House held that NASA
you know effort results that later had
to be retracted and I think that that's
you know it's kind of a pre you know
cursor they're actually giving it some
deep thought saying Oh
was only published online I'm not gonna
pay attention to it now on the other
hand there have been attacks on it that
it's not mathematically rigorous and I
think those are valid but it's not valid
in my opinion especially in the case of
Stephen because what Stephen has done is
he's made it completely public so he's
he's listed all the code and we'll get
into the details of it and his
philosophy in general he laid it out as
I said in my podcast for the arthur c
clarke center called in to the
impossible which we'll put a link to or
it's on my youtube channel it's the best
place to look so i should say on my
youtube channel when i do an interview
with an author like what I do with
Stephen and did with Peter Diamandis
what we'll talk about maybe next week or
Sarah skulls will talk to me the week
after these interviews are put online on
iTunes in the podcast your favorite
podcast or but they're also put on
YouTube and the YouTube has some bonus
features in that you can see videos
b-roll footage links to pictures other
videos it's more much more interactive
and we include show notes with many of
the episodes as well so we want people
to really dig into it so I've given
exercises for the reader to kind of
listener the viewer whatever to go
through in that podcast so please do
thanks Brian no really yeah well do you
want me to show your clip yeah that's
alright let me do it can be short of a
better future today I contacted you
because I like so many of my colleagues
are so excited about this new physics
project that will firm is involved with
and that you pioneered I want to
understand how it came to be how you
were inspired by young people in your
life because we have a mission here to
inspire the imagination of young and old
and and this particular was kicked off
by young people and how it's made its
way into the world but that connection
to technology sort of intrigued me when
I when I had that realization that you
had completed more calculations by
orders of magnitude
than any other device invented before
the computer LSA it made me think like
what what would have happened you know
had you been born a century earlier for
example were born into technology that
we have and there are certain bounds on
what technology you can create and
you've you proposed this new physics
project but would that have been
possible you know thirty years earlier
or fifty years what do you feel about
that yeah I think the answer is
basically no for two reasons first
reason is a really practical one which
is you know part of how we know what's
true is by doing experiments we can now
do computational experiments that's a
fairly new thing if we've been a lot lot
smarter than we are we might have been
able to figure out what was true without
doing the experiments but I don't think
that's feasible so the first thing is
the practicality of being able to do
computer experiments the second thing is
the way of thinking about things that
computation has brought to us is
something that comes about because we're
just used to computation all around us
and that's that's a sort of paradigmatic
advance that I just think is not
achievable without sort of a lot of
exposure to computation in the wild so
to speak on that didn't deal with some
editing skills there I'm working with
many projects and he's a member of the
production / du sirs Guild of America
all right well there's your taste guys
of the interview go to so you do the way
you listen to it you're like you could
either get it on iTunes and or go to his
channel and get the extras as well
one thing I've learned about doing this
Brian and one of the reasons I'm here
and thanks in large part to let me give
a shout out to James Dugan who's from
Australia he's what he's here he is like
begging me to you know continue to make
content on YouTube because people don't
like to switch platforms all that much
and so you know James is one of the best
you know viewers I've had for a long
time and I really care about what he
thinks and so I want to make content
that he can enjoy and get at the
platforms that he accesses and so what
you're doing here is really a good thing
because you want to be on the platforms
where these people are and a lot of
people hopefully my god my audience you
guys will
go and check out some of these things so
what was the thing about that interview
just give us a little what you know
inside into look about what he's like
and one of the some of the things maybe
the one or two things you learned from
the interview well you know I start
talking to him and his publicist or
assistant rather and she had said well
the interview you know how long is it
and I said well it could be you know as
short as half an hour or something like
that or could be as long as he wants and
she said well he only talks you know
beyond 30 minutes or so if he has
respect for the person who's talking to
us so it's gonna be a short interview
yeah exactly but we ended up speaking as
you can see for two and a half hours and
I debated whether I should break it into
two videos or into one I just left it as
one you know he said such a brilliant
intellect that I felt that even though
people were criticizing him online some
of my best friends most renowned members
in the scientific academies they were
saying you know they basically don't buy
it it's not worth you know looking into
because nothing really fruitful had come
out of his previous book which was our
previous extensive book on physics where
he made a big claim about science and
that was called a new kind of science
and they were saying you know they were
dismissive and so I was a little bit
hesitant to just do kind of a fawning
gushingly positive interview of him
because I know that there's a lot of
skepticism about the the both the
veracity of what he's done the claims
that he's making how bold audacious they
are that he's really unified or has a
path to the unification of physics look
Tony one of the things that comes out of
his physics project is essentially the
speed of light which before cut you know
it comes out of Maxwell's equations but
it doesn't it's not a prediction of math
well Maxwell's equations we have to go
out and measure things indices of
refraction a speed of propagation and
then now it's a defined quantity but in
his new physics project it actually
emerges from the properties of space and
time themselves so that's pretty
intimidating that's pretty audacious
and I want it to be fair to both sides I
want to give him a chance because he's
such a brute I mean no one could deny
this guy got his PhD at age 20 from
Caltech a small Technical College you
may have heard of it
yeah so and he was the youngest
MacArthur Genius grant winner so this
guy and he's found in multiple companies
his company's flagship product is in
your pocket right now
it's called Wolfram Alpha and it runs on
the device that spelled Si RI and many
other things that I want to set off too
many too many smartphones etc but the
bottom line is this grants had a huge
impact oh and by the way he worked on a
small movie called a rival now all that
being said that doesn't give him a pass
he still has to pass through the rigors
of being confronted with the acceptance
and veracity of his claims and so I got
into that with him and I wanted to go
into it with him because he's a heart a
mathematician a philosopher a logician
and I said look one of the things that I
want to talk to you about is the
so-called falsifiability of your theory
is it possible to prove your theory not
right
but to prove it wrong in fact will it be
possible for it to merely evade all
possible tests and therefore escape you
know kind of by by the judicious 'no
sucks jury or lack thereof or does it
actually make a bold prediction that
will see you know certain properties of
black holes when they coalesce they
should manifest certain properties in
their waveforms in their signals and he
discussed that with me and that was the
first time I think he had really
discussed that look when we get to Uncle
Bill's question because yeah it's what
I'm thinking the same thing over so it
might as well just he's he's putting it
a little bit better than I would he's
asking doesn't it matter that he is
inviting peer review I mean why is it
wrong that he's self-published and the
peer review must happen publicly after
the fact why is that wrong I mean why
are why are people getting yet
so bent out of shape that he publishes
it first and invites peer review later
well I think I want to be fair to both
sides so there is this notion that peer
review is the hallmark of science I want
to point out as I think he might have in
this in this journal that how old do you
think peer review is how old do I think
it is I think yeah probably it's
probably something started in the 19th
century somewhere in there maybe some
definitely after Newton
that's right certainly afternoon Newton
Galileo and many people before them
published themselves they published
pamphlets right yeah Galileo Darwin was
a peer-reviewed I mean the entire
species that's right and in fact we
spoke a lot Stephan and I spoke a lot
about Darwin the influence on it and
there is a certain you know he has a
very healthy sense of the stakes that
are at play and even of his own
abilities and I like to say you know
he's earned a lot but he's earned as
much as a listening to
there are also my colleagues who say
he's grandstanding he's not he's not
actually doing anything and I point out
one of the things that this comes to in
the end is that it's sort of a network
theory it's sort of a network the way
that space and time are integrated to
one another is sort of based on these
very simple rules of propagation in
these abstract spaces related to things
called Hilbert spaces I don't get into
it but he describes in detail in in the
paper there's a four hundred and fifty
nine page paper that he put on the
archive which I'm a link to in the show
notes and so it's not that you know he's
hiding anything the other thing is that
he's made code available to do these
things now my main question to him Tony
in all honesty is is this just a
semantic question in other words if you
say that you know I was explaining to
one of my kids the other day I said look
at that tree you see how like the branch
you know fork shot into into two pieces
and then those fork down the tube that's
called a fractal there's self-similar
patterns that are exhibited throughout
many different realms of nature and a
lot of the patterns that he generates in
in the physics project are look a lot
like fractals they have certain property
similar to the so called game of life
not the board game but the John Conway
the late John Conway now and and the
question is is it semantics are you just
saying that like things in nature are
fractals or are you saying and therefore
you know there's rich structure
self-similarity fractional dimensions or
are you saying something that there's
actually source code for the universe
that's running on some operating system
and it does that require consciousness
so that's what we got into and that's
what I kind of pressed him on and I
thought his answers are very interesting
you know he's a student of history and
you must listen to him you don't have to
agree with him but you're gonna have a
hard time really kind of pointing out
where
the logical flaws are you might not
agree with his presentation on the other
hand right and well that that's
definitely an invitation to listen to
the to the full interview then because I
would love to hear what he has to say on
that so yeah okay well when you get to a
couple comments here cosmo safari on
twitch is commenting how the current
scientific community continues to be
that of privilege and fame he also
caught he also has a question do we know
the potential technological implications
that could result if we had a theory of
everything
what technological links would there be
so it's very interesting when you talk
about theories of everything they could
be they can classify into two different
camps essentially there's sort of the
camp that steven is in where he's
looking at the fundamental rules in sort
of a computational perspective in other
words there's sort of the theory of
everything would be a rule and he's not
actually claiming a theory of everything
he's claiming that a fundamental theory
of physics at its heart is operating
according to simple rules those simple
rules will exhibit patterns and we can
compare those patterns to various
structures that we see in the universe
therefore you know just as your computer
can't make a pattern that it's coding or
it's hardware is incompatible with
almost by definition that you'll sort of
learn the source code of the universe so
he thinks of everything through the lens
of computation I didn't appreciate that
until I had this interview with him on
the other hand Shimon like Einstein or
his pseudonym or you know similar name
homonym Eric Weinstein they have
geometric theories and the geometric
properties of space and time are
encoding boundary conditions on the
behaviors of particles of fields of
forces the fact that space-time has a
certain number of dimensions will mean
in that case that you can only have
certain types of motions or you can only
have certain types of particles those
particles can only have certain types of
properties their spin their mass their
charge those will behave in certain ways
depending on the geometric structure in
which they're inherited within now those
are very different things right you
can't you can imagine that you could
take a Stephen Wolfram program and think
about a way to you
operate an iPhone better or you know or
solve a quantum computing problem better
or rule out certain theories of physics
even so he claims he can rule out
something called the simulation
hypothesis I want to not gonna get into
that it's fascinating I want to talk to
you about that some other time that's
basically that we're in the matrix right
now
yeah that one yeah why Stein is saying
something completely different it has no
practical you know it's like how many
practical innovations have come from the
fact that there's you know three
generations of leptons no I mean how do
you like oh I have a faster you know
Google phone so now I can because of
these three generations of leptons
nobody says that but they are inherited
from the fact that the space of
mathematics the geometric space has
certain properties so I in one if one of
them is right Steven then there could
potentially be vast implications for
practical benefits for example okay all
right
so I had a great question here and I did
you scroll past me oh I know what I
wanted to ask you this is just for me
why why is this assumption and it's
starting to get on my nerves why Steve
is doing it certainly in most major
minds and science do it why does this
basic assumption the universe operates
on a set of basic simple principles why
in the hell does it have to be simple I
don't I've never understood that why
does it happen he produced why does the
entire universe have to be reduced down
to an equation that fits on a t-shirt
please explain to me where that comes
from because it doesn't seem obvious to
me that that's yeah well what else well
one of the people I most want to have on
is sort of a critic of mine who was
really harsh in her review of my book
but she's a brilliant scientist in
Germany or named Sabine Hasenpfeffer I
hope to get her on my podcast soon too
she has a book that's a best-seller
called lost in math and her thesis is
that physicists are drawn to the
attractive or unattractive aspects of
the theories mathematics in other words
a physical theory describes the
properties of matter of energy of
space-time itself
there's no reason according to her it
should be beautiful now when we say
something should thank you should I
agree with that statement okay that's
her statement I understated there are a
lot of physicists
yeah okay good I want to get her on my
show so that you and I can talk about
the interview that I do with her on my
podcast so hopefully she'll be she'll be
continent okay but but the other camp
says no there I've actually been great
breakthroughs using pure mathematical
concepts such as the concept of symmetry
and even the concept that symmetry when
it's slightly broken have you ever seen
these pictures maybe you're the folks
out have seen this where you take a
human face like Brad Pitt who's like the
handsomest guy in the world next to Tony
right next to you in a space they divide
his face in half and then they reflect
his face back on its other side so in
other words his left and right side of
his face are forced to be mirror
symmetric he looks completely disfigured
he looks and you'd say it like he's not
the sexiest man alive it's back to Tony
but but in reality that's because the
human brain interprets certain things as
beautiful and those things that are
beautiful are but usually symmetric but
they can't be too symmetric they can't
be too perfect
what she's saying is that these two
perfect images that we're seeing from
people are messages and physics are
contaminating the way that physicists do
things so it really Cleaves to whether
or not you think physics is almost like
an art form in that it inherits the
symmetry the beauty the elegance and
compactification you'd agree that a
hundred pages of equations is less
elegant
perhaps less beautiful than a single
line which could sit on a t-shirt that
doesn't mean that's right
but but I'm just saying that's the drive
that she claims has corrupted physics
and held it back over the last 50 years
she basic limbs have been almost nothing
in the last 45 years that's been a true
breakthrough in theoretical physics III
really I can't wait to hear this
interview because I like her already
that's exactly right we I wonder where
the new innovation where is the where
are our big contributions in physics it
hasn't really been anything other than a
fleshing out of stuff that happened in
the 20th century so I think I think
she's got a really good point there yeah
so yeah all right
cosmos Safari is also oh wait better and
better I want to get to his question
where did where did it go
it was Oh No
I'm sorry okay better and better is
asking a wouldn't any legit theory of
everything have to have the speed of
light emerge from it if it's legitimate
a speed of light better be in there
somewhere
yeah that's certainly true so the theory
of everything is merely going to not
merely I shouldn't say that it's it's
tremendous accomplishment if it's ever
achieved it's going to combine the laws
of electromagnetism where the theory the
speed of light is manifest what's
different about Wolfram's theory is that
it is sort of really kind of looking to
provide a reason for its particular
value not that it has it has can have an
arbitrary value in other words there'll
be some parameter which by virtue of the
laws are encoded in the theory of
everything tell you perhaps what the
masses of every particle should be right
now we measure those those are used as
input to our theories and we tune the
theory or we tune you know we look at
the data and we examine the likelihood
of a theory given that data set or
sometimes the reverse but anyway the
point is the parameters are usually
taken as inputs that you must measure
but on the other hand it would be nice
to have a theory that predicts these are
the values that you're gonna see like a
prime number hypothesis in mathematics
could tell you what are the properties
of the next prime after the biggest
problem that you've ever discovered so
that's what it means to have something
emerge from the physical theory itself
so we don't have a theory that tells us
that without any parameters without
measuring the properties of the of the
vacuum or without measuring the speed of
light itself with with the various ways
that we have of doing it okay we only
got a couple more minutes and I want to
make sure I get some of these out so uh
atom synergies commenting wolfram maybe
grandstanding but at least his work
isn't hidden from everyday people behind
a paywall amen brother amen brother I
hear ya and cosmos Safari I feel like
the best science is done in the open
many of the ideas of twenty-somethings
are historically the best work done in
the life of a scientist or an artist etc
many times people waste a lifetime
trying to gain consensus on their ideas
enough to be published and they tiptoe
around their ideas to keep them from
being blocked from publication
it's very interesting that's a very good
point and it's it's impressive that the
question is cosmos cosmos is a teacher
so I know him okay I mean it really is
digging into the sociology so there's a
notion and you know at least among
physicists that everything is applied
physics so except for math so math is
needed to provide the roots and the
foundation of the tree in which grows
physics and then for out of physics
comes chemistry biology comes from
chemistry etc but lay way down in the
branches in terms of our higher up
towards the heavens if you will is like
sociology and psychology and I think
this question that is being asked is is
relevant because it's saying you know
what what is the sort of reaction now I
disagree I don't think that people do
their best work in their twenties I used
to have this conversation with my father
who was a mathematician he said people
don't do their best work in their 20s
they do their best work over a 10-year
period which is usually you know
associated correlated if you will but
not caused by their age after they get
out of their undergraduate or the PhD
but I've known people that have done
phenomenal work as they got older in
fact an experimental physicist or even
any fit a theoretical physicist
never does their best work in their 20s
we it's you'll be hard-pressed to find
somebody who does outside of an Einstein
or somebody like that because you
haven't physics is about accumulating
knowledge and wisdom about the events of
the universe and you simply don't have
enough of a toolkit when you're 21 or 22
it's that it's not possible but usually
you need that acquired wisdom which
takes time whereas mathematics it's a
little bit of a different subject but
even there I think if you got your PhD
in math at age 30 you could still do
great work up until your forties and
even your fifties and beyond okay well I
just want to be clear on one thing about
peer review I want to make sure that I
am clear on the idea that I think peer
review is vital that it does not happen
without so I mean science it depends on
it and it is not something I'm trying to
downplay there eyes'll it is a human
endeavor and within without people
checking your work for mistakes or you
know making sure it's consistent with
the body of knowledge that we've already
gathered all of that makes peer review
quite important but I do think
that there is become there's a lot of
barriers to new ideas as a result of
peer review process so that's what yeah
look what is peer review it's an
adversarial process and that means that
you have to hide it has to be with two
people that have a common goal in mind
it can't be to take someone down like on
Twitter
it could be oh I want to flame somebody
and insult somebody but in a journal it
shouldn't be about that you shouldn't
have you know people ad hominem
attacking and sometimes unfortunately
Tony I've read terrible thing especially
recently fellowships just got announced
for certain very prestigious graduate
fellowships and I've heard like these
poor students writing reports that like
the referee said that they're they're
you know they're not very good and their
careers or you know not likely to be
very successful and that they only got
to a certain place because of a certain
reason it's very insulting and it's
because it's anonymous so you know
you'll say something very different to
me in person or when I'm looking at you
then you will say to me on the internet
or anonymously and actually one of your
in the chat room somebody just said
talking about the psychology of science
I can't read their name but it says
scientists are the same psychologically
as other people and thus are limited and
have herd mentality I disagree with the
latter part it doesn't necessarily imply
that we have herd mentality but we are
human despite the stereotypes which when
because of that we have biases and we're
just a normal person in that way and
sometimes we're biased against
authorities and were biased against
novelty good okay quick question from
John suffle some years ago a
mathematician was just just to pass the
time working on a 15 dimensional
mathematics and found he drew unified
relatively relativity and quantum
physics would this be valid in the real
world I think that this is he might be
referring to Eric Weinstein who is a
mathematician okay did have a he did
have this talk at Oxford in 2013 so that
would comport with the statement about a
few years ago Eric does claim to have a
higher dimensional representation that
encodes the properties of gravity
properties of quantum mechanics the
properties of dark matter etc and like I
said he's tentatively agreed to come on
my podcast and I do want to talk about
these issues with him and as I said I
don't give anybody a free pass but I'm
also not sixty minutes I'm not going to
show what did you do you know some
people was like why don't you ask
stephen wolfram about his employees the
following a lawsuit I'm not 60 minutes
sorry go to another channel this is the
one expose exactly are you gonna stop
eating your grad students whoa maybe ask
about that
alright so anything else you want but
you're kind of what I think we've done
your your time here so anything else you
want to remind people of before you head
out yeah I would really like to you know
kind of leverage a lot of the synergy
that your channel has of mine and and
your listeners and viewers I I recorded
you know 42 different episodes over the
years some you like some you love some
you late but the bottom line is I get
some of the greatest intellects because
of where I am at UCSD in the arthur c--
clark center for human imagination that
i get the opportunity to talk with nobel
prize winners with pulitzer prize
winners with a live interview with an
astronaut while she was in outer space
and i want to talk about that with you
at some point to how do we communicate
stem to the people my mission as I say
in my book is all about you know getting
you guys out there return on your
investment you guys pay my salary as a
scientist and supported by the federal
government I feel and I'm also a state
employee of the state of California I
love to share the knowledge I've gotten
and most of the knowledge I've ever got
in my life came from books I love books
I love ideas and so give us a hint that
what we should name this segment on on
deep astronomy we'd love to have you
listen I'd love to have you watch the
full videos on my youtube channel which
is dr. Bryan Keating Dr Bryan Keating on
YouTube if you can't figure it out and
then also go to the into the impossible
podcast leave a rating review and then
you'll be entered you can get entered
into a competition to win Stephens
latest book and I will do that for the
author the listeners on the iTunes
podcast all right great
so what do we want to talk about next
week just skim a little we talked about
a briefly what do you want I think we
should next week we should talk about
dr. Mario Livio he has a new book coming
out called Galileo and the sign
deniers and Mario is a world-famous
author of the of the golden ratio and
why and brilliant blunders he's a friend
of mine and we're gonna do a podcast
with him tomorrow and I'll be up on
Tuesday
and I'll send you a snippet and folks
can come you know can chat about that so
it's a little bit more kind of down to
down to earth in some sense and that
he's not clean you know he's talking
about Galileo and the first scientist
maybe some say the first scientists in
history to use the scientific method and
what became of his life after he came
out and declared that the Copernican
sun-centered universe was the true
nature of reality I'd love to hear
that's what that's gonna be a good
interview because I actually I got to
interview Mario I worked with him at the
Institute and yeah he brilliant blenders
came out he I was one of the first
hangouts he had done this was like right
before he had done the Stephen Colbert
episode so yeah so Mario olivio is our
awesome guy we'll talk about him next
week I'd love to hear read his new book
actually as well so okay folks so I'm
gonna stick around for a little while
got about 20 more minutes I'm gonna
stick around chat with you guys for a
while about whatever you guys want to
talk about and we'll be back next week
so Brian thanks for joining man thank
you guys yeah really a lot of fun being
with you Tony thank you looking forward
to doing more of these all right okay
bye bye well you got a brief look at the
Drake Equation there I don't know why I
have that sitting in here but I just do
hey guys okay well what do you guys
think of this thing is it's gonna be
something you'll watch on Thursdays or
not you guys have some great comments
and I really appreciate your feedback on
this no it's not over yet galaxia but i
am you know he's has other things to do
on thursdays so we're gonna make it an
hour but he's gonna be on probably for a
half an hour just kind of get wet your
whistle on what to go look at and I'll
stick around and chat with you guys
dan I'm not having a flat earther on my
program there ain't no there's no point
zero point and talking to flat earthers
other than to
give them attention that I'd rather not
convey so I'm not talking to me there's
nothing you can talk to about what
you're gonna do they're just gonna use
it to troll science anyway so so there
we go
it's best my thought on that Hans is hey
Hans it's good to see you and better and
better thank you guys very much listen
one of the things you guys if you want
to support this I'm just gonna start
being blatant about it you can do the
Super chats and they really do help last
week I got a couple of super chats that
really helped this channel I know I took
down the discord server because I didn't
want you to be compelled I'm not talking
about discord patreon campaign because I
didn't want to compel anybody to support
if you still want to you can just by
going to deep astronomy dots calm slash
donate or you can just do it here or
with the super chats and all that kind
of stuff it all goes to the same spot
which is by the way you know I should
also mention I am in desperate need of a
camera you may know you may have noticed
there's been a lot of noise and cameras
here my main video camera is is on the
fritz it's just stopped working so I
need to somehow afford a new camera so
for now you know into any any help you
can give would go towards that
okay so Adam says he that he passed the
audition thanks Adam I appreciate it so
hey Lance Lance Lance left took on
Twitter twitch it's good to see you and
Uncle Bill's here as well and yes if you
do go to the discord server better and
better just posted I should have a bot
that posts this but I guess it's not
doing it right now so yeah I appreciate
that
I still think dark matter is just normal
matter that we've forgotten our
calculations yeah what we gotten it when
Hubble telescope was launched thirty
years ago we still haven't discovered
any exoplanets at all back then we
hadn't yes there's a there there's a way
in which you can measure the mass of the
universe without actually having seen
all of it
I strongly believe Dark Matter somehow
connected with negative mass